je pense vraiment que l'opinion publique
en ukraine est très divisé il y en a
certains qui veulent absolument pas
troaré cette idée d'une invasion qui
disent même je regarde pas les nouvelles
non non espace rien d'autre qui ont peur
d'autres qui vraiment ont du mal à lire
et à comprendre et à savoir est-ce qu'il
faut plus croire les américains qui sont
vraiment très inquiet et on peine à
comprendre pourquoi ils seraient six
inquiet s'il n'y avait pas de quoi
s'inquiéter et évidemment c'est un grand
pays qui a des services de
renseignements extrêmement compétents et
donc vous avez des ukrainiens qui
commence à penser si nos dirigeants nous
disent qu'il faut rester au calme alors
que les américains sont vraiment inquiet
peut-être que c'est qu'on devrait plutôt
avoir confiance en les américains il
faut savoir que 60 plus de 60% des
ukrainiens ne sont pas très contents de
la direction dans laquelle valeur pays
donc ce n'est pas un gouvernement qui
est extrêmement populaire mais de
l'autre côté les analystes les
intellectuels ukrainien qui se posent
calme on regarde la situation la vraie
nature de ces forces russes de l'autre
côté de la frontière les vrais scénarios
possibles pense que le scénario d'une
invasion proprement dite avec des forces
qui traverserait la frontière des forces
russes qui viendraient en ukraine est
probablement le moins plausible des
scénarios ils craignent beaucoup plus un
scénario où la russie est serré de créer
la confusion de créer des problèmes à
l'intérieur de l'ukraine avec une
escalade du conflit tall d'une baston
l'est du pays par exemple ou encore avec
des cyberattaques